- [Narrator] The sound you hear emanating
from your speakers,
that low, ominous tone,
is not a signal problem or
a defect of poor recording.
It's but a sample of what
brings us all the way
to the American Southwest,
to investigate an infamous phenomenon
known simply as The Taos hum.
This October, on Friday the 13th,
from an executive producer
of The Walking Dead,
and an executive producer of The X-files,
comes six terrifying tales,
based on the podcast phenomenon, Lore.
Until then, we offer you this short film,
inspired by the series.
- I'm Steve Iannuccilli.
I'm a professor of anatomy and physiology
at St. Joseph's College.
The Taos Hum is a strange
phenomenon that happens
in a town called Taos, New Mexico.
What it is basically is people in Taos,
about two percent of the people, hear this
strange humming sound
or this buzzing sound
that really irritates them,
gets into their heads,
gives them headaches, gives
them anxiety, gives them fears,
and people don't know really
where it's coming from.
- [Narrator] This persistent sound
emerges seemingly from nowhere
and plagues those who hear it
day and night without relief.
First thought to be a disorder consistent
with the high-pitched ringing of tinnitus,
doctors have become puzzled
by patients' accounts
that they are able to move freely toward
or away from the phantom sound.
- They describe it as maybe a
low rumble of a diesel engine
or maybe a really loud refrigerator noise.
- [Narrator] And while the
description of the sound
is consistent from all
who claim to hear it,
the intensity varies widely.
A dull annoyance to some
but an unyielding nightmare for others.
- It ruins people's lives because they can
never get away from the sound.
All day, all the time, in
your ears, in your head.
Some people have been driven to suicide
because of the Taos Hum.
It really does affect the
patients really badly.
- [Narrator] Some scientists theorize
that the hum could be caused
by regional seismic shifts,
while others blame low
frequency radio signals
used by the military at
classified sites in the desert.
- If you wanna go down
the conspiracy route,
some people talk about the U.S. Military
using ELF technology.
ELF technology could also
be used against your enemies
as a type of warfare where it will cause
headaches, and it will cause
noises to be heard in the ears
and ringing in the ears, and it will drive
your enemies crazy if
you make the frequency
perfect to where it really irritates them.
- [Narrator] Others
still look to the Navajo,
Apache, and Hopi teachings
that identify the hum
as the song of long lost spirits
trying to speak to us from the other side.
- [Steve] New Mexico is one of those areas
that's still rich in the
culture of the Native Americans,
and they believe that it's the Earth.
The Earth is talking to you.
- [Narrator] In the end, we
may never truly understand
the origin or meaning behind the sound,
and it seems those affected
must resign themselves
to its effect or uproot their entire lives
to move away from it, but somewhere,
resonating in the depths
beneath the surface,
the unseen source
continues to faithfully hum
for anyone who will listen.
(tone ringing)